a scandal over a lewd document has ended
the season for one of Harvard's biggest
sports programs the university abruptly
canceled all of its men's soccer games
yesterday the teams in first place in
the Ivy League a student-run newspaper
uncovered a sexually explicit scouting
report in which players rated the
appearance of women athletes Dana
Jacobson is here with the fallout Dana
good morning good morning Anthony the
document in question dates back to 2012
but school officials say the so-called
scouting reports by male players
continued into this year and while the
men's soccer team may have its season
over the impact from this controversy
will be felt across campus on the campus
of Harvard University the reaction was
swift the 9 page document from 2012 was
first uncovered last month by the
student-run newspaper the Harvard
Crimson which detailed a sexually
explicit evaluation of incoming female
freshman soccer players by a member of
the men's team that list was then
emailed to teammates with some
responding called the scouting reports
the list cataloged the women based on
physical appearance their sexual appeal
numerical scores and in some cases
described in detail a sexual position
assigned to each woman the crimson
became aware of the documents a couple
of weeks ago muriel klein is the
president of the Harvard Crimson and a
senior at the University it was a
publicly available document on the
Internet it was actually taken down
after we contacted the members of the
2012 men's soccer team for comment after
the article was published late last
month
school administrators opened an
investigation which concluded the lewd
scouting reports were more widespread
across the team than previously thought
and the practice had continued into this
year the remainder of the men's season
was then canceled severe measures
measures had to be taken it might have
been a little excessive to completely
call off the team guys crossed the line
a lot and I think that's one of these
instances last week six members of the
2012 women's soccer team who were ranked
in that sexually explicit scouting
report penned a collective op-ed in the
Crimson in response to the document
saying in part the sad reality is that
we have
come to expect this kind of behavior
from so many men we are frustrated that
this is a reality they wanted to show
that they were resilient and they wanted
to call women to come together to be
able to hopefully stop this type of
behavior in the future
in a statement Harvard University
president drew faust said the team's
behavior and the failure to be
forthcoming have no place at Harvard and
run counter to the mutual respect that
is a core value of our community I love
that these women are speaking up and
that once again they're raising the the
phrase locker room conversation yeah
their op-ed is wonderful that you know
they said it's not okay to say that this
is a locker room talk and they said they
were so appalled that these women who
are strong women and athletes are being
reduced to physical objects they
encouraged all women to sort of band
together and even ask the men's soccer
team to now do something positive going
forward and to ban with them as they try
to make something good come out of it
and get the conversation going would be
great if men would speak out to saying
this is not okay yeah and they did point
out also this is not all men right not
condemn men forthright thank you very
much Dana